maybe you maybe heard about this this
story a bunch of high school students in
Wisconsin at Baraboo high school in
Wisconsin they were getting together for
their junior prom I think this is back
last spring and we're just now talking
about it for some reason but they're
getting together for their for their for
their junior prom and before the the
prom they you know we're taking a
picture and whoever took whoever was the
one snapping the photo
suggested that they make what appears to
be the Nazi salute and so they did that
and the picture was taken of these kids
doing the Nazi salute and somehow months
later this ends up going viral and and
it's it's it's headline news it's on CNN
it's on all the news channel everyone's
talking about it it's it's you know
everyone is it's but it's saying well
this this shows where we are a society
that this is an epidemic this is a
crisis and and now we're told that the
police a police department in Wisconsin
the local police department they are
assisting the school district in
investigating the photo there is now a
police investigation of inappropriate
hand gestures made by high school
students in a junior prom photo and the
crazy thing is that is that you know
I've seen this reported at several
different places I've seen it on social
media about the police investigation and
Oh from what I've seen almost nobody is
is pointing out how crazy that is that
for the police to be nobody is even
questioning like is that really a police
matter what crime is committed here it's
a it's a stupid ugly offensive
photograph that these kids took and they
should be in trouble with the school
they should be they should they should
get the tension at the very least if we
want to talk about suspensions well
that's up to the school district to
decide but clearly there should be some
there should be some penalties even
though this didn't happen on school
property but what what's the police's
role here what's what what what are they
going to pull each one of these kids in
have them in the interrogation room do
the good cop bad cop routine
and to investigate what we already know
what they did you could see the photo
yes they it appears they made the Nazi
salute yes that is offensive
yes it's ugly yes it's stupid yes it's
outrageous and you know something and I
just want to I want to tell you
something about about high school boy
boys here this is something that
apparently a lot of people seem to
forget or seem not to realize somehow
that it's a it's a stupid offensive
outrageous bad thing that's why the high
school boys did it because they think
it's funny okay so if they get it into
their heads that something will be
really offensive and will cause caused a
ruckus and will upset people they're
going to do it for that reason not
because they they are expressing support
for Nazi ideology maybe some of these
kid maybe some of these sixteen-year-old
boys really are dyed-in-the-wool
Nazis but I tend to doubt it I think
most likely none of them are Nazis I
think most likely if they were you know
none of them are attending neo-nazi
rallies or anything like that I think
that's very likely that none of them are
in that category they just realized that
it's an offensive thing and so in their
teenage boy brain they say to themselves
this is offensive so it's gonna be funny
and so they do it that that's the
calculation that teenage boys make it's
not appropriate it's immature they
should be taught a lesson they should be
disciplined by the school but it's not a
crime it's not headline news for
goodness sakes
and it's not something that everyone in
the country needs to be concerned about
and it's also not something that we can
take and extrapolate from that some sort
of national emergency but that of course
is what the left is doing in there
saying well this is you know you start
getting the hot takes and the think
piece is about you see this shows you
what's really going on in white America
that they're all a bunch of Nazis it
shows it shows you know such a thing all
it shows you is the immature
calculations of this of a
sixteen-year-old boys brain and again
that calculation is offensive stupid
equals funny that's the calculus a very
simple calculus and oftentimes it can
lead high school boys in bad directions
I'm gonna tell you something and I don't
mean to scandalize anybody here but I
this is actually not the first time high
school boys have made inappropriate hand
gestures in a photograph it's not the
first time high school boys have have
have taken photographs doing
inappropriate things in general this is
a favorite pastime of high school boys
because they think it's funny that
doesn't make it right that doesn't mean
they shouldn't be disciplined but it
does mean that it's insane for the
police to be involved and it does mean
that there is no reason whatsoever for
this to be national news because this is
something we should all already know
about high school boys okay
I'm not supporting the photograph I am
simply saying that it's it's maybe a
little bit of proportionality could
could come in handy here you know we we
have very little we have we have a lot
of trouble keeping things having a
proportional view of things and whatever
the latest controversy is we we
automatically said well this is the most
important thing in the world right now
and everything is a crisis everything is
an emergency everything is a symptom of
some greater problem and bla bla bla we
have no understanding of human nature we
especially have no understanding of the
ways that I love the way that teenage
boys operate we just we have lost all
sense of that altogether and and so it
leads to absurdities like this so I
think everyone just needs to calm down
all right something else I wanted to one
other quick thing before I get to them
to the meat of the discussion today
Democrats in the house are now saying
that they're not gonna try to impeach
Brett calves and all the man that they
claim is a serial rapist representative
Nadler who's the ranking Democrat in the
House Judiciary Committee told CNN State
of the Union on Sunday that he does not
plan to go down that road of course he's
not gonna go down that road because he
knows that there's nothing down that
road for them to find except for more
embarrassment and and for themselves
obviously the the the Democratic
witch-hunt against
Cavanaugh did hurt the Democrats in the
midterms especially in the Senate but it
did hurt them nearly as much as it
should have I mean we don't know exactly
how much it hurt them what it what the
results would have been had they not
gone through that whole smear campaign
but I think it's clear that it did but
not as much as it should have
almost the entire Democrat Party on the
federal level was complicit in this
scheme to take these fabricated
allegations and destroy a man's life or
try to anyway just to keep them off the
Supreme Court as I've been saying now
for weeks it's is one of the most
dishonest smear campaigns that I think
we have ever seen in American political
history and I and I know that that is
saying quite a bit but I also think that
it's true in this case and therefore the
consequences for the Democrats should
have been far-reaching and long-lasting
but they really aren't you know they're
suffering some consequences but not
nearly to the extent in the level that
they should suffer those consequences
and this is the problem I think with the
way things work now is that we move on
from things so quickly partly because of
the story I mentioned right at the top
that there's a lot of stories like that
these these stupid irrelevant stories
that have no relevance to anyone's life
outside of the outside of the individual
is actually concerned in the story
itself but no relevance to anyone else
there's really nothing for any of any of
us to say about it other than to wag our
fingers and say well that's not good I
mean that's all you can read that's all
the analysis that is necessary or that
could really be offered is you shouldn't
do that okay let's move on
but there's there is a never-ending
supply of those kinds of dumb stories so
we're always just moving on to the next
thing
even if the thing that we're on right
now is actually important and and we
should spend more time talking about it
we can't because you know a high school
boy made an inappropriate hand gesture
so we got to move on to the next thing
and we should we should we should be
clear about this that our capacity our
our willingness to always move on to the
next thing to never really hold anyone
accountable
anymore this this is not this does not
stem from forgiveness I I wish that I
could say that it did you know that it
was at least well-intentioned so we're
very forgiving people so that's why
yeah the Democrats orchestrated this
terrible campaign and they're you know
they they conspired amongst themselves
to take these fabricated allegations so
on and so forth I wish that we could say
well well yes well we just we've we've
we've we forgive them for now I don't
think we should forgive them for that
but at least I could say well that it's
at least well-intentioned but that's
this is not forgiveness this is just
nobody can stay focused on it we have
the we just don't have the attention
span for it anymore and that's why I
think that we may be living in a time
where career-ending political scandals
no longer exist I think we may be living
in a way we're living in a post scandal
society because anyone can basically
survive any scandal if they managed to
hang on through the initial storm for
you know a few days if they can just
hang on through that which which which
indeed can be a very intense time
because when we are focused on a
particular story we're extremely focused
on sometimes too focused on it but then
we can't it doesn't last it's just a
bright burning star and and it just goes
away it explodes it goes away very
quickly
um Trump is famous for saying that he
could shoot a guy on Fifth Avenue and
his supporters would stick by him why I
think that's true of pretty much
everyone these days and you know nobody
has the the capacity to continue caring
about something for more than four or
five days so I think it's true of pretty
much pretty much any politician can
survive any scandal it's not just that's
not just Trump I could shoot a guy on
Fifth Avenue it's it's any other
politician could and because we're just
gonna move on and forget about it and
move on to the next thing and this I
think segues nicely into the the main
topic that I'd like to discuss because
somebody else in the world has benefited
greatly from this dynamic recently and
that would be Pope Francis now in
another time in another era
I think we would still be talking about
the fact that the Pope was accused in
writing in detail by an archbishop and
former high-ranking Vatican official of
personally and deliberately ignoring and
even helping to cover up the sexual
predations of a high-ranking Cardinal
that is a huge story that in a different
decade and different era we would still
be talking about that even though it's
been a few months since it originally
came out it is even if we don't treat it
like it it is one of the biggest stories
of the decade easily and and without
without question the biggest religious
news story in a very long time whether
you're Catholic or not the Pope is an
extremely powerful man an extremely
influential figure and he's the head of
a religion that claims over a billion
adherents so this is big stuff this is
big news and then vegan Oh archbishop
vegan oh the man who wrote the original
letter he's going on to write several
more letters that have gotten no
attention whatsoever but he's elaborated
on his accusations and given more detail
provided more detail so these are
credible documented allegations that he
that he is he is not back down from he
swears by them and to this day the Pope
has not answered the accusations he has
not responded yet he has not denied them
he hasn't said anything about them other
than to accuse those of us who want
answers of essentially being in league
with the devil that's what he said
just the regular letting regular lay
Catholics who are concerned about this
and who would like to know what's going
on we are we you know we are victimizing
him we're victimizing the Pope that's
that's essentially what Pope Francis has
said multiple times and now and now the
story yesterday is that what we should
back up for a minute there's a there's a
a US bishops conference happening in
Baltimore as we speak and it was
scheduled for November 12 to 2 November
14th
and what the bishops were supposed to be
doing is they're supposed to come up
with you know come up with a strategy to
deal with the scandals and to deal with
all the the sex crimes in the church and
everything supposed to come up with a
new code of conduct they were supposed
to develop a a body of people to
investigate bishops accused of
misconduct it was supposed to be a lay
led body that is a body that has led not
by other bishops but by laypeople and so
they had a whole agenda of things that
they were supposed to be doing during
this conference actual results right an
actual strategy a plan and people who
are cynical like myself we already
doubted we were very skeptical that they
would actually come forward with any
kind of real solid active plan to
address the problem but now we know that
there's not gonna be any plan because
orders came from on high orders came
from the Vatican to cancel the vote that
the bishops were supposed to hold on sex
abuse reform measures the Vatican has
now told the bishops not to have any
vote on it and not to come up with any
plan or at least not to a vote on any
plan not to institute anything he would
they were told to cancel it and the
story is well they're gonna meet again
in a few months oh you know over in Rome
and then maybe then they'll come up with
a plan I mean this is it's absolutely
incredible they you see how just how
angry people are especially ordinary lay
Catholics demanding answers and so
finally the bishops are getting together
they're supposed to come up with a plan
and in the Vatican swoops in at the last
minute and says come up don't come up
with a plan actually no plan
now I suppose is a good time to mention
that there's gonna be a rally in
Baltimore this afternoon to coincide
with the bishops conference which is
still ongoing even though there's no
point of the bishops conference anymore
because what's the point why do they all
get together if they're not gonna come
up with a plan but there is gonna be a
rally to protest the scandal and
corruption in the church and to demand a
plan to demand answers accountability
I'm gonna be speaking at the rally I
have a lot to say about it I'm not gonna
give my speech here but I will say my
gloves are off
even though my gloves are all I never
have gloves on my gloves are always off
as I'm sure you've noticed so I'm not
gonna I won't get into the whole
diatribe here I'll save that for for the
rally but I will say this Pope Francis
was sold to us by the media as a
reformer you know as a guy that would
get in there and do things differently
and and clear the deck and all that
stuff and he is no such thing
Pope Francis for all of the despite his
reputation as this you know as this Pope
who goes by the beat of his own drum and
isn't afraid of controversy and all that
stuff despite that he is no reformer he
is a defender of the status quo that's
that's what Pope Francis will really go
down in history as is he is a a valiant
defender of the status quo and that's a
huge problem because the status quo in
the church right now and in the
hierarchy is terrible but that's what
he's interested in is defending it and
keeping it in place and as as we have
found out according to vegan oh not just
keeping it in place but making it worse
taking some of the most corrupt
Cardinals in the world like mckarrick
and in in in rescuing them from
obscurity to from the obscurity that he
had been he had been exiled to by
Benedict plucking him out of that
obscurity and install
him back into positions of power and
influence in the church that's what Pope
Francis has done and it is shameful and
it is disgraceful
so Catholics are left wondering what are
they to do and and to anyone who is not
a Catholic I think it may be helpful for
you to understand just how this all
breaks down because if people ask me all
the time they don't really understand
the dynamics of the church and you know
how Catholics deal with this and what
we're allowed to say about it well we're
allowed to say whatever we want about it
but there are I should tell you there
are a few schools of thought among
Catholics with respect to how we should
approach this issue and how we should
approach the Pope and how we should
frame our criticisms of him or whether
we should criticize him at all so there
are a few screwed schools of thought and
I'll tell you what the schools are the
first school of thought is more of a
school of unthought it's a school of no
thought and these are the Catholics who
don't really care don't know what's
going on don't have any clue I couldn't
care less and this is probably the
largest school in Catholicism at least
in America just as it's the law it's the
largest school in every group every
religion every demographic every
denomination the largest groups always
going to be the the unthinking lemmings
who just go along with the flow and
there are plenty of those among
Catholics the next group would be people
who love Francis and love what he's
doing they love his liberalizing
approach and so they're willing to
overlook or deny or outright lie about
the things that Francis is doing wrong
and they will and and what I've
discovered specially recently is that
these people are are especially
shameless they they will make absolute
fools of themselves so for instance Pope
Francis is is accused credibly of doing
this horrible thing helping to cover up
these crimes and sins of a high-ranking
Cardinal refuses to say anything to this
day has remained silent
well the Pope's liberal defenders
have tied themselves into pretzels
trying to justify the Pope's silence and
trying to kind of trying to sort of
intellectualize and moralize his silence
so if you go online you can find these
these beautifully written but totally
bogus and ridiculous explanations by
liberal Catholics trying to try to show
us the real meaning behind Pope
Francis's silence his silence is no it's
not it's not cowardly science silence
it's not the silence of a man who just
doesn't care
that that the people in his church are
are severely distraught over all that no
it's not the silence of that it's not
the silence of uncaring it's not the
silence of cowardice it's it's a
courageous silence it is a it is a
prayerful deep profound silence you know
so we have to it is it is it is it is
like the or or an or another thing
they'll say is it's like the silence of
Jesus when he was questioned by Herod
now both of these explanations are
terrible the first one is just stupid
the second one is to is to suggest well
you're making Pope Francis Jesus in this
scenario and then Herod is who Herod are
so the lay Catholics who just want an
explanation I want to know what's going
on there there Herod now you're
comparing them to Herod so there's that
group and then the next group are people
who who believe that it's their duty as
Catholics to defend the Pope not Francis
specifically but the Pope whoever it is
the papacy they believe that it's
improper if not sinful to publicly
criticize church leadership they know
that the Pope is not infallible in all
of his pronouncements and that Pope's
have only issued infallible decrees very
rarely in the history of the church and
then only on matters of pre-existent
doctrine in other words not to invent
new doctrine but to reaffirm reinforce
reaffirm codify existent doctrine so
they know that but they feel kind of
dinked of li that they're called the
support everything the Pope does anyway
and they're very uncomfortable with the
idea of criticizing them and so there
are people like that in the church the
next group are people who won't defend
the Pope but do feel that it's their
duty to remain silent obediently
and say nothing so there's that group as
well and then there's the next school of
thought this is where I am situated and
in that group there are those who have
great respect for the office the offices
of leadership in the church but we do
not feel called we do not feel obligated
to sit silently in the face of
corruption um we think that the laity
must speak up must make their voices
heard must defend the truth defend what
is right even if it means defending
truth and defending rightness against
the Pope himself so if the Pope is
threatening what is true and what is
right then we defend what is true and
right against him against anyone against
anyone who would threaten against anyone
who would deny it against anyone who
would try to cover up the truth so there
is that group in the church and I think
it's a group that is growing in numbers
and then there's the final group which I
don't even you can't really say that
they're in the church but there's a
group that I'm certainly not a part of a
group called the set of a consists and
they think the Francis is a little is
not a legitimate Pope anyway we haven't
had a legitimate Pope in many decades
they say different things about who was
the last legitimate Pope they kind of
decide they seem to all decide on their
own who they think was legitimate and
who wasn't but so there's that group as
well more kind of a fringe group very
small now the the sort of unthinking
fans of Francis who actively defend him
dishonestly defend him no matter what I
have no respect for that position
I find it disgraceful honestly and
cowardly and I have nothing good to say
about it the visceral defenses of the
Pope generally of whoever happens to be
the Pope I think this is very much the
wrong
Oh shoo and it is also less and less
tenable in modern times you know to me
that that that mindset is it's it is a
holdover from the Middle Ages and it
just doesn't work anymore because you
know back in the old days if you were
Catholic sitting in a church in Spain or
France or whatever you know hundreds of
years ago you really wouldn't have known
what was going on in Rome you wouldn't
have known what the Pope was doing
saying you know you you would you would
have every once in a while you get a
pronouncement you get a decree you get
whatever and usually you would hear
those pronouncements a it would be read
to you in church or something but you
would hear them those things would come
out at the conclusion of some kind of
controversy some sort of unrest some
sort of dispute and so you're hearing
about the controversy the dispute after
it's already been settled and that's
just how it was before the Information
Age but we now live in a time where
where we know about all these things we
know what's going on we know what the
church is doing we know about these
scandals we know about the corruption we
know about vegan owes testimony we know
all of that we have that knowledge we
can't pretend we don't know it and I
know that there are many people in the
church who would like to pretend they
don't know it but they can't because we
do and so we have to do something and
it's true that there's not you know
there there isn't one step that we can
take there's no switch that we can flip
to fix the problem but I do think we
could start at the very least with with
speaking up and making it clear that we
are not okay with this that at the very
least is step one
and that's what today the rally in
Baltimore is gonna be about so if you're
if you're a local and you want to come
out to that I hope to see you there
otherwise I'll talk to everybody
tomorrow Godspeed